e cette fois la nouvelle est donc
officiel je vous le disais en titre nier
nicolas et cécilia sarkozy on divorcer
par consentement mutuel c'est par un
très bref communiqué qu après des
semaines d'interrogations l'elysée a
confirmé la séparation du couple
présidentiel
il était marié depuis 11 ans le
président de la république qui est à
lisbonne ce soir pour le sommet européen
qui n'a fait aucun commentaire
véronique saint-aulaye frédéric basket
il est 18 heures le président de la
république arrive à lisbonne pour le
sommet européen compagnie de bernard
kouchner sourire de circonstance sourire
de fonction nicolas sarkozy donne change
mais ses traits sont tirés pas d'
échange d'amabilités avec ceux qui
l'accompagnent juste un coup de fil sur
son portable
depuis ce matin l'elysée a mis fin à la
rumeur oui cécilia et nicolas sarkozy
d'yves ans le premier communiqué
officiel et transmis aux agences de
presse
avec l' annonce d'une séparation par
consentement mutuel précision à 15h21
séparation signifie divorce
enfin il est 15 heures 45 le divorce est
qualifiée consentement mutuel
donc depuis le lundi dernier monsieur et
madame sarkozy son divorce est prononcé
15 octobre dernier on se souvient de la
dernière image de cécilia et nicolas
sarkozy côte à côte
c'était sur le perron de l'elysée le 14
juillet dernier
depuis de rumeurs en confidences sur les
difficultés du couple
la pression médiatique n'a cessé
d'enfler il apparaît ces derniers jours
que c'est cécilia sarkozy qui a souhaité
qu enfin le divorce soit officialisée
réactions politiques contrastés les
peines de coeur du président de la
république
e
les français s'en fiche chez nous aussi
nous préférons nous consacrer nous
focaliser sur les problèmes
politique du pays n'empêche pas le
président de la république tout à fait à
la hauteur de sa tâche à la hauteur de
ce que peut attendre la france d'un
président de la république il tristesse
affiché pour une amie du couple
ils sont tous les deux exactement comme
malheureusement des milliers de français
qui après avoir vécu ensemble ou être
marié se séparent c'est à dire ce sont
des sentiments contrastés complexe c'est
un mélange de tristesse de sérénité de
questions de christ c'est si difficile
c'est difficile pour tout le monde c'est
évidemment difficile pour eux c'est la
première fois en france qu'un président
de la république divorce pendant son
mandat nicolas sarkozy à 52 ans reflète
aussi l'évolution de la société et la
banalisation du divorce
cela ne semble pas choquer les français
qui attendent d'abord la réussite des
réformes promises